Hello everybody, hope that you are good.
Today is the day, is the FOMC meeting.
Okay, so it's going to be a day with a
lot of volatility, spikes up and down.
So, I would suggest to keep your
positions light, to not be overexposed.
You know, be a strict with your risk
management because there is going to be
quite a lot false moves probably during
the FOMC. That's at 6:00 p.m. UTC time.
Now, what we are expecting, everybody is
expecting this is this is priced in is
25 basis points hike.
Everybody's pricing that in, okay?
So, the market is not going to react to
it when when they announce it. But, what
they are what the market is going to
react to is going to be the press
conference, the words of Jerome Powell.
And I want to hear what Jerome Powell
has to say about the debt ceiling
because Yellen said recently that they
are running out of money.
So, let's see what he says about the
debt ceiling. Also, the federal funds
futures market, they're pricing in a
hike of 25 basis points now today.
And then, three rate cuts this year of
25 basis points each. So, the most
likely thing is that Jerome Powell comes
out today and says, you know, "What I'm
not going to be What I'm not going to do
any rate cuts this year."
He said that they back in the 22nd of
March, the previous FOMC. So, the most
likely thing is that he says the same
thing.
Okay? Now, is he going to also say that
they're going to pause rates here?
Or that there might be more hikes? Cuz
if he says that there is going to be
more hikes, then the DXY is going to go
up, Bitcoin is going to go down.
Recession.
They're going to ask him about
recession. Let's see what he has to say
about it.
Now, it's You know, the past I remember
that they were always trying to avoid
that word. The word recession. Then, in
March, in the FOMC minutes, we could see
that they say that they're expecting a
mild recession over the next 2 years
with high inflation, also.
So, I think that we're going to have a
very interesting press conference. There
are a lot of questions, difficult
questions that the journalists can ask
Jerome Powell. I'm sure right now he's
there with his team
trying to figure it out all the answers
for any possible question. Because there
are a lot of things they can ask him,
okay? You know, all those things that I
just I just said. Now, let's go with
Bitcoin because yesterday we had the
move to 28,400.
We placed this arrow and price went
there because the market maker is
watching these videos.
Um now, to be honest, the prediction
could have been quite a lot better
because it really went to the 4-hour 50
MA, you can see. Okay, maybe I was too
conservative and that was a mistake, but
you can see that price went to the
4-hour 50 MA, then it did some
consolidation below resistance with some
spikes up.
You can see in these weeks and that
means
according to my to my logic, that it's
because the market maker is building his
shorts. You can see with this candle.
All right. Um now, if we check I want to
go really quickly to the to the
to the S&P.
Let me check that really quickly.
Because I want to show you what I did
yesterday.
Okay? We were saying that yesterday it
would have to test this zone as support
and then it could have marched higher,
but it didn't. So, prices went back
inside the range, okay? That was the
other scenario that we had in mind. Now,
the 4-hour 50 MA is going to be the
resistance. You know, here it was the
support, you can see.
And now it's it's becoming resistance.
So, let's see how it reacts. In my
opinion, this candle here, what happened
yesterday,
that's in anticipation
of the FOMC meeting. And that's
basically because the institutions, the
the investors, they are just being
careful because they know there is going
to be quite a lot of volatility, so they
have they do a sell-off the day before.
That's that's what I think, okay? Let's
go back to Bitcoin really quickly.
Let's see
um
where we are right now. Interesting
thing is that they haven't still
filled this week.
Maybe that's the next move, okay? But, I
would like to first draw what market the
the zones of interest in the chart. We
have the week, we have this this
liquidity pool. Let's see what else I
can see.
Um I can see a liquidity pool here, too.
And another one here.
Okay? Now, let me get this here, copy
and paste
to mark these zones.
Okay. And let's remove the 50 EMA. So,
in my opinion, these are the zones of
interest in the chart. Now, today there
is going to be a lot of volatility with
the press conference, I think. So, the
most likely thing is that price do some
wild moves.
I think it's very likely
that today
we might see the week getting filled
and even
probably, too,
one of these liquidity pools or even
both. Cuz I'm telling you, markets
are going to be
quite wild.
I think this week is quite likely
because I'm expecting
Jerome Powell saying that there is not
going to be rate cuts this year, that
there might be more more rate increases,
maybe. They're going to be data
dependent, but for now probably they're
going to pause. Let's see what happens,
but I think this week, you know, any
word he says
it will trigger the move because there
are, you know, there there are
algorithms playing with keywords.
So, it's going to be live, you're going
to see in live that he says the word um
"potential new hikes" and you're going
to see a candle in the 1-minute time
frame doing this.
It's simple as that. It's a very
difficult and and and it's not
recommended to have trades open during
that time. So, what I would suggest is
to not have any positions open or any
limits orders set until the press
conference finishes, okay? And that
means, look, let me put it here for you.
Uh I think the the FOMC starts at 6:00.
Uh uh this is UTC time.
And then the press conference, I think
it starts at 6:30 UTC time. Okay, so
those are the times that we're going to
have all the information.
So, I would suggest
to not trade
uh 30 minutes before it starts the FOMC.
Um
and also, let me think.
The press conference probably lasts
about 30-45 minutes.
Um so, I would say probably
until
quarter past 7:00.
Okay?
And I'm going to call this
no
trading during.
Okay?
Um
So, yes, basically I'm not going to
trade 30 minutes before the FOMC starts.
And I'm not going to trade
until at least quarter past 7:00. So,
I'm going to give it a bit of room
to get all the information from the
FOMC, the press conference, see how they
may see how the market reacts. And then,
yes, you can trade imbalances because if
we go and we see what happened
previously
in the 22nd of March, that was the last
FOMC meeting. Let's have a look.
15-minute time frame.
Um let's go to the 22nd of March. It's
here. Okay, let's have a look. Let's
check this.
All right. So, you can see
how we had a clear resistance in this
zone. And then, at 6:00,
you know, they what they did is a stop
hunt, you know, a spike above that
resistance and then dump
all the way here and this is
I checked earlier, this should be a
$2,200
move.
Sorry, you can't see there.
This is a 200 2,300 dollar move.
Then, after the press conference, you
can see that price was
trying to retrace this imbalance.
Because yes, you can see all these large
weeks, that's a liquidity pool. Um this
is another liquidity pool.
This is another liquidity pool. So,
there is quite a lot of liquidity pools
here that need to be re-reached. You can
see there is a week here that also got
filled. Um that's what happened. A lot
of moves, a lot of volatility, a massive
move.
And then, they have to retrace the
imbalance. So, what we could expect to
see today, let me go back to today.
Let's see if we can figure it out.
Uh so, if we if they drop another 2,000
from here,
I mean,
that's a long way. Geez. Uh 1-hour time
frame, let me check.
I mean, what they could do is
What about
if they take us even lower? What about
if they go below this zone? Okay? What
about this if they do something like
this?
I'm just trying to to think, okay? Fill
the week
and go even a bit lower.
And then,
we may have something like this
and try to fill
this
later on. I would say probably before
the weekend, okay? But, it should be
before the weekend. So, what about if we
see something like this today?
You know, go below these lows,
fill the week, you know, a lot a lot of
liquidity pools in this zone,
and then retrace them.
Or we could see that it's impossible to
know because we don't know what he's
going to say today.
But, I'm expecting that he's not going
to be dovish. I'm expecting him to be
quite quite hawkish because I think he's
going to attack the Federal Funds
Futures market. So, the first move that
I'm expecting,
I might be wrong, is to go to the
downside
and then retrace that up. But, who
knows? Just, you know,
uh I'm going to wait because this we
might see this by inverted to the upside
and see this and see something like
this, you know?
Who knows?
And then retrace, and this would
probably go which also would make sense
above these highs here.
So, why not? We could see something like
this, also. So, I would suggest you guys
to wait, be patient. I think if you open
a trade before the FOMC,
that's pretty much gambling. I so
uh wait until the FOMC, wait wait until
the fresh conference finishes, see the
imbalance they've created, and then yes,
you can start to think about trading
those imbalances. So, thank you guys for
watching,
and I'll see you soon.